hello everyone i'm alana welcome to my
channel where today we are talking about
grand theft
auto 6. basically
there is become a trend of just every
single month
on twitter um grand theft auto 6 starts
to trend again
someone has new rumors there are new
leaks um i think that this
image illustrates pretty well why um
this is from twitter they said because
gta 6 is trending again
and then uploaded this image of the
games that came out within
seven years so from 2001 to 2008 we got
gta 3
vice city san andreas and gta 4.
that is pretty wild uh and then in the
past eight years being from 2013
to 2021 we've had grand theft auto 5
grand theft auto 5 grand theft auto 5
and grand theft auto 5. so naturally
i'm not going to knock it um i
understand why people really want
to hear gta 6 news and i have zero doubt
that gta 6 is being worked on
literally literally zero of course
they're working on gta 6.
did you think they weren't come on now
there are a couple of topics that i want
to get to but i thought that i would
cover
today's news first or i think this news
actually came out yesterday um
about basically the gta
5 ps5 and xbox series x port
oh this article here the article says
strauss zelnick ceo of rockstar games
parent company take 2 interactive has
discussed the company's approach to
remasters saying that it won't settle
for simple ports of its older games
including the upcoming version of gta 5
for ps5 and xbox series x
slash s as transcribed by vgc
zelnick made the statement during a
morgan stanley technology conference
when asked about the importance of
remasters for take two going forward
he said remastering has always been a
part of the strategy we've done
differently than the competition we
don't just port titles over we actually
take the time to do the very best job we
can making the title different for the
new release
for the new technology we're launching
on it we improve the technology we
upgrade the visuals and we make
performance enhancements and that's why
i think our remastered titles typically
do
so well and this is where zelnick said
i'm confident that rockstar is going to
deliver just a great experience but you
can't do that if you're just
doing a simple port as zelnick puts it
they're interested in making the title
different in some capacity
and it has also kind of been teased in
the past if we pull this article over
from
svg uh the gta voice actors have teased
a gta online return this happened in
july last year but it's also been spoken
about kind of on and off for a pretty
long time the
short of this um basically says a few
months back gta 5 acts as sean foteno
and ned luke who played franklin and
michael respectively did a live stream
together on instagram
where they discussed their time working
on the series and answered some fan
questions
uh fontano basically mentioned that
rockstar was still focused on producing
new content for grand theft auto online
and he gave rockstar a shout out
and said we're waiting to do our online
roles but yeah to add to this luke said
he'd love to be the person handing out
the new jobs during an upcoming heist
and fontana replied i heard
they had something coming up with us to
do with that so
wait and see this definitely seems like
they could have just been poking fun
with each other or just having a kind of
conversation
um i don't imagine uh rockstar doesn't
have
you know a good strict set of ndas
on uh the voice actors but to me when i
saw this clip it definitely seemed like
one of them was trying to keep it a
secret and the other one was like
excited um and and so one person is
trying to rain the other person back and
trying not to leak something but i mean
that is just very anecdotal it could
mean absolutely anything
regardless the truth is grand theft auto
online
is so mind-boggling profitable
that take two could have a case for
never wanting to make another grand
theft auto game ever again
if that's what they really wanted to do
gta 5 has made more money than any film
book or game says analyst uh industry
analyst doug kritz says
grand theft auto 5 has made more money
than any other form of media
in history with over 90 million units
sold total and
6 billion in revenue the game is made
more than blockbuster movies like star
wars and gone with the wind which both
brought in
around three billion dollars in theaters
when adjusted for inflation
even with the estimated income from home
entertainment sales which he puts in the
ballpark of an extra billion
they do not come close to grand theft
auto 5.
and i think part of this that's
particularly interesting is uh
kurt saying i'm sure i'm butchering that
last name i think it's a wild
outlier that's not to say rockstar won't
have other big hits it may but another
gta 5 isn't likely
michael jackson had a lot of hit albums
but he only had one thriller
essentially grand theft auto 5 and gta
online just make so much money
that there isn't an incentive for them
to push out gta 6 really quickly there
is much more of an incentive
for them to push out another grand theft
auto 5 on
modern consoles and that's the thing
that i think will be really interesting
going forward um
obviously red dead redemption 2 has come
out since gta 5 came out red dead
redemption 2
is a very well polished
beautiful game and i am very glad that
it exists and that rockstar has the
caliber of writing
in video games that they do take two
though who is rockstar's parent company
slash publisher obviously
has also said a bunch of stuff recently
um the amount of games that they plan to
release
in the next several years was like it
was an absurd number
let me make sure i can check that actual
number take two has plans on releasing
93 games in the next five years
that is wild i think that um yeah that
came out the news came out last year but
just wanted to double check
definitely something that they are still
intending to do uh this is from game
rant and says yeah last year rockstar
games parent company take two
interactive announced that it will
release 93 video games in the next five
years
after the company's recent earnings call
take two reasserts it will move forward
with its plan to deliver the 93 new
games along with a few other details it
includes 63 core experiences 17
mid core games and 12 casual slash
arcade games across
various platforms this is probably some
mobile in here i would think uh take two
president said it was a snapshot during
that point and the company's still
moving forward with creating a large
number of new games while the company
hasn't made
any new updates or official announcement
on those titles he's confident the
company's progress is
still reaching that goal 47 of the game
releases will be based on existing game
ip with the rest being
brand new so here's why i bring that up
i think that we are actually pretty
likely and i hope we are very likely to
get a lot
of grand theft auto remasters i think we
are likely to get three by city
which is currently my background and san
andreas at the very least
i think we are likely to get a red dead
redemption one and i think those things
are also probably in development
at the same time that grand theft auto 6
is being worked on but my main point
here is they have absolutely no rush
in making gta 6. and every time it
trends and every time people want new
info
um i always just kind of want to be like
why are we trying to rush this you know
i made a video about this just last week
if it even if it even was a week ago at
this point which kind of touched on how
upset people seem to get when we get a
release date too early or information
about a game too early
or i don't know a lot of people express
dislike of something being marketed for
four years the whole thing that i always
think about this kind of thing is like
yes gta 6 is going to repeatedly be
rumored uh
course rockstar is working on gta 6 of
course they are also working on
hopefully improvements for gta online on
a slew of remasters
tag 2 did also say every game they would
have going forward would have
microtransactions so yes your next gta
is going to have micro transactions and
i think that the bigger problem that
rockstar has right now is figuring out
how to
support gta online at the same time as
releasing gta 6 and do they update both
of those things at once i feel like a
fortnight approach to gta online is kind
of required alongside
some story content for gta 6 but i don't
see the story content going anywhere is
my point
it's just not in any kind of rush for
the studio nor for their publisher and
nor should it be for anyone who's
excited about it this stuff is
way more rewarding if we wait until the
publisher or the studio is ready
to tell us what information they want to
when they give us their own footage
uh when they give us a release date or
an indication of something at the right
time because
yeah i feel like i always see people
bounce off of things being released too
early and and they don't understand why
this keeps happening the one thing that
that flags this to me is the fact that
uh
dan hauser left rockstar
uh february 2020 this is from bbc i
guess it was mainstream enough to make
bbc news
dan hauser is leaving the firm he
started with his brother sam in 1998.
mr hauser was the main creative force
behind the two of the firm's biggest
series grand theft auto and red dead
his departure comes after an extended
break rockstar's parent company take 2
interactive said rockstar's series have
often quoted controversy but are among
the best-selling and most critically
acclaimed games of the past two decades
which is definitely correct he will
officially depart in march so that was
march of last year according to a
take-two notice sent to us
financial regulators his brother sam
will remain as the company's president
dan hauser was one of the lead writers
on the grand theft auto series as well
as rockstar's other hits bully and red
dead redemption he also worked as a
voice actor on some of the company's
projects
so that's obviously a huge thing
especially for
the way that the company uh functions
narratively but i will say as someone
who works as a writer at
a studio uh the writing is not ever done
by one person
and with games the size of rockstars
games
they are certainly not uh going to
immediately move away from a passion for
writing
strong stories after most recently
releasing red dead redemption 2 and
getting
critical um praise for that but yes to
to take it a step back from there
um not just my own you know guesses
about
where the company's at which from my
head is they're doing extremely well i
can't imagine them changing anything but
they also again do not need to rush out
a story especially with a change to
their their writing team that's that
significant but i also just think that
every time that that we
uh demand information online i mean a
rockstar's not gonna do it they kind of
tend to do whatever they want
whenever they want they have tremendous
marketing budgets
and will have no problem marketing the
game as they please when they please
but it's just that a big part of it is
you know do we really want
information before it's ready this is
always my thing with leaks is
is there's plenty of stuff plenty of
games that i could have leaked
information about games that i could
leak cool anticipated games that i have
seen
that i could share information on but i
don't feel like it actually serves
anyone
it screws over the dev team and the
publisher but it also screws over the
public like it also screws over gamers
it means that you're getting information
before it's necessarily ready it's at a
point where it could still change
which is the case for most things that
leak or even most games that are
announced
too soon and detailed too soon as they
change and then people get mad when
they've changed but it could also be way
too far away and it could be frustrating
to have this thing held over your head
that you keep hearing about that hasn't
released yet and that's a really common
sentiment
so is gta 6 going to come out yes
eventually in some form it will come out
i think we will also get remakes
of most games in rockstar's library
which is very exciting to me
big fan of virtually all of their games
and i do think they have an interesting
road ahead of them with what to do
between the split with um red dead
online gta online and then
you know how much they might have to
update things
when uh gta 6 shows up but in closing
all i will say is and i gave them a
shout out recently
um being a patient gamer i think pays
off in a lot of ways
if you wait for video games and you wait
for video games announcements
video games announcements you are more
likely to set yourself some realistic
expectations
and uh not kind of have that weird
drought where you've been waiting for
something for too long
and generally rockstar really do
innovate they move the industry forward
in a lot of
really impressive ways i think their
open world ai has consistently blown
away so many developers i know
i remember talking to someone just about
gta 4 i think it was
um someone who worked in dev just about
the way that pedestrians would
occasionally
lift to put like a newspaper over their
heads if it started raining
and then obviously the way that um red
dead 2
has the i don't know the npcs feel like
they have
real lives it's uh
it's a studio that really does push
things and move things forward in a way
that um
i think is worth waiting for even though
they have had their
fair share of controversies uh certainly
not perfect
but you know part of it is that we also
um know that
a lot of rockstar employees were saying
that they were working 100 hour weeks on
red dead redemption 2
and i would much prefer if they did not
work 100 hour work weeks to make grand
theft auto 6 so rockstar
take your time that is pretty much it
for me today everyone i will see you
guys next time bye